roll is a simple everybody say it with
me
uh-huh you laugh or you lose say now
last one got taken down from copyright
strike two of them I don't really know
why I bother even making these all the
effort on editing and try to make it my
own it's completely pointless this video
will probably be deleted as well so
really the challenge is you get
copyright strike you loose like YouTube
isn't hard enough these days what the
[ __ ] am i doing I'm a struggling
youtuber now this is what happened but
you brought this on yourself pubes you
got damn right I did
you're welcome let's do this your life
you're loose alright whatever guy here
was she trying to do this advanced
equation 248 minus 200 Oh Plus that's
6000 oh my god well she was closed to be
fair she just got it
she did she yes you forgot to add the 1
to the 4 it's a it's pretty cute it's
kind of like the people that mix up this
palette spelling you and you're
introducing with your new personal
assistant Alexa Johnson this whatever
you need all you have to do is ask Alexa
Jones well what is it - Alexa what do
you do teach people about the sexual
pleasure of eating turds
shut down infrastructure Subaru thing to
China I love Alex Jones but like move
your you sure not unit is so low the
heroes Dennis
[Music]
under the chin union children come
Saqqara Cupertino Yodas swore ever to
Okinawa
if
[Music]
say kynos or neohart virginity wait that
works
[Music]
[Laughter]
to create my virgin boy
so stay the in Scituate what's that
Dragon Ball Z
what an amazing anime I need to watch
[Music]
in order to feelin's hazard this is what
you face me or your genetic just
happening face your inhalation wait what
is this he puts it puts it on a cow oh
okay that's cool
I need to play that game again god damn
it the gifts from it is amazing other
woman's so as you can imagine medieval
castles were not easy to break into they
were basically like those jungle gym
things at chuck-e-cheeses
massive in size intentionally confusing
layout security everywhere and by the
end of your visit you probably end up
with some kind of disease so in order to
help penetrate fortresses medieval
armies would often utilize siege weapons
one of the most popular of which was the
trebuchet now this device is interesting
enough on its own but it gets better
so around 1300 ad king Park officials of
England was in the process of invading
Scotland however one fortress known as
Stirling Castle was giving him a lot of
trouble he laid siege to the building
for many months without any real
progress then one day he woke up and had
a revelation hey guys listen why are we
wasting our time and building all these
regular sized ricochets where we could
just build one giant one and call it a
day so that's what he did this
gargantuan war machine was known as the
war wolf and stood at around six stories
tall to give a bit of perspective this
is about as tall as King Kong was in his
largest film depiction so basically make
sure a giant from ape launching boulders
like their baseballs and you've got a
pretty good idea of what the war wolf
was capable of it was so intimidating
that when the scots saw the english
constructing the beast outside the
castle
they immediately surrendered out of fear
but then edward was like huh that i'm
gonna test this bad boy out and
proceeded to take potshots on the castle
any oh see we need this is the stuff we
need happening it's too many passive
aggressive people on social media
because no one's out killing each other
[Music]
how to make a blockbuster okay have you
ever wondered about this particular
thing because it turns out that that
thing is real
all right I get it they're all the same
classic Omaha mu Cindy
great what has happened endless trash
okay great I think I've just lost the
ability to laugh can I give you a list
of historical figures prominent figures
from history and you'll tell me whether
or not they were white or black shoot
give me the best shot where did we start
okay um
Beethoven black Mozart black Cleopatra
she looked black but she was what she
looked I like my question it's not just
being judge bad but the seed of your
father William Shakespeare without
Abraham Lincoln that's still in debate
what you mean you don't know he's like a
white and we're not seeing a lot of
confidence ability Christopher Columbus
whose way Henry the a black what if they
judge it from yes you fine drink hot
girls you're hot drink more expensive
cars a street money you in a tuxedo
[Music]
please drink responsibly because they
have to put that thing in there god
these are so awkward all right okay one
three three donates $5 hello from Sweden
so I've been watching gdq for two years
now and today i just found out that my
grandpa died two hours ago
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a VR game well then that's fine
that has to be staged but that is pretty
good well done
oh cool
[Music]
that's great
oh hell yeah
did you laugh oh did you lose Wow
hopefully this didn't get copyright
strike check out in the description the
video if you want to check it out
they'll they may get a strike but at
least you won't get me
junk in media that's right I'm pulling
you up what you gonna do
copyright this one oh I bet you want to
I bet you're trembling off do we have
the intellectual property of this one
nah I said no not today leave a like if
you liked and leave a like if you don't
thank you I'm your host killer keemstar
but it's wrong with me thank you guys so
much for watching and as always say
you're Nara oh my oh Moo